a woman from China accused of illegally
entering president Trump's mar-a-lago
Resort is due in court today Secret
Service says you jingzhong reached the
reception desk before she was stopped
last month she allegedly was carrying
two Chinese passports for cell phones at
a thumbdrive full of malicious software
Manuel Bojorquez is at the federal
courthouse in West Palm Beach where the
case is being heard many good morning
good morning the purpose of the hearing
here this afternoon will be to determine
whether Zhang should be released on bond
federal prosecutors believe she is a
flight risk
her arrest is raising concerns about
foreign agents infiltrating mar-a-lago
know I'm not concerned to know I have
very good control president Trump
defends the security measures at
mar-a-lago his so-called winter white
house last weekend an intruder named
using Jang claiming to speak limited
English
apparently bluffed her way past two
Secret Service checkpoints she was
finally foiled by a receptionist at the
resort's main building I think that was
just a fluke situation and I think that
the person sitting at the front desk
very good job Zhang told a judge last
week she was in the US for business she
claims to be an investment consultant
drives a BMW and owns a house in China
worth about 1.3 million dollars if you
are there for legitimate business
reasons it seems odd that you'd have
malware on your thumb drive right former
CIA officer Lisa Ruth says Zhang's
explanation for being at mar-a-lago
rings hollow this looks very much like a
Chinese espionage intelligence operation
the president was at his nearby golf
course when Zhang was arrested according
to federal prosecutors Zhang claimed she
was meeting a friend named Charles at
mar-a-lago for an event organized by the
United Nations Chinese American
Association that group was reportedly
founded by a man named Charles Lee
according to the Miami Herald Lee and
another woman Cindy yang often promoted
events at mar-a-lago as a way for
China's elites to gain access to the
president yang also says she is the
former owner of a chain of massage
parlors that prosecutors now allege are
really brothels
one of the purported clients at a parlor
she formerly owned is New England
Patriots owner Robert Kraft a good
friend of the presidents and a frequent
visitor to mar-a-lago Ruth says the
exclusive resort which charges a
$200,000 initiation fee is a gaping hole
for foreign intelligence services
certainly President Trump is the the
biggest target but there's a lot of
other people at mar-a-lago who have
access or information or intelligence
you have seasonal employees who are
certainly not cleared like a White House
employees going to be recruit any of
them and you've got a lot of information
j'onn is charged with lying to federal
agents and entering a restricted
building she is not expected to enter a
plea until her arraignment next week as
for Cindy yang her representatives tell
CBS News she does not know Jean at all
Nora right well thank you I think it's a
fascinating story more about intrigue
there a lot of intrigue and more to meet
the idea this feels like the story is
not going to get less interesting